Speaker 1: Let's continue our tour of different
races across the country, some of them scarier
than others. Today, we're going to look at
California Republican Secretary of State
candidate Rachel Ham, who has decided to run for
office because her son found Jesus inside a closet
in her house. This is really wacky stuff. And we
are going to look at a couple of clips of her.
Here is Rachel Ham, again, candidate for secretary
of state in California. She's a Republican talking
to us about how she is trying to use prayer. To
steal votes back. So this this is very convoluted.
She believes Democrats are stealing votes and
she's going to pray for God to send angels to
steal the votes back now. Why wouldn't God
just prevent the vote theft to begin with?
We'll never know. But take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: I would pray that I win. One thing that
I've been doing is praying that if anyone tries
to steal a vote, that God would send the angels
to steal the vote back to make it an honest vote.
Yeah, I think we might as well ask. I mean, angels
are, you know, they can do things. They can do.
Speaker 1: Jobs. So I think we should
get a lot of them are actually in
unions. They prefer a union work.
Speaker 4: A job with the election. Help us
make it an honest one. So, angels, if there
are any fake ballots that have been produced,
burn them out, find them and destroy them. If
votes are flipped and the machines flipped
away from the candidate someone voted for,
flip it back and I don't care which way. If it's
from me to someone else. Because that was honest
to make it an honest vote. Right. So I'm not
asking for cheating. I'm not asking the angels to
cheat. I'm asking the angels to prevent cheating.
Speaker 1: Right now, with all of these things,
I always kind of apply a kind of like
an Occam's Razor thing, which is,
first of all, if there is a God, is God really
concerned with the election of the California
secretary of state or would God be more worried
about bigger issues? And then they can come back
and say, well, God is all powerful and God is
all knowing. So God is involved in everything
God's involved in. Does that banana that you
ate does did it does it have food poisoning?
Are you going to get sick from the banana or
is it. God's involved in everything. Okay,
well. So why is she even running? She
explained that she's running because
of something about Jesus being in her closet.
Speaker 4: What what was the the the reason behind
deciding to run for this office?
Speaker 2: I mean, you've got a.
Speaker 4: Lot of things. First of all,
I'm a prophetic dreamer. So I had spent
a lot of 20, 19 and 20 having a lot of
political dreams that I was in office.
Right. And because our youngest son, Ezekiel, is
this year, I went and got him and I said, hey,
can you look around and see what you're seeing?
Speaker 1: Because and now there's a real question
as to whether her son, through heredity, became
a seer or whether it's something he learned.
Speaker 4: I just really I get a kick out of
hearing him describe what he sees. And so I said,
let me know if you see anything. And so he looked
in my bedroom and my bathroom. He said, there's
nothing there. And then he goes into the closet,
which is where I had been when I was praying.
Right. And he said, whoa, in his eyes, like bigger
saucers. And you kind of like started backing away
and they started bending down and he said,
You've got a really big guy in your closet,
and his power is pushing me to the ground. We
had never he'd never had that reaction ever
to an angel. And so I'm like, is he he's
he's for us, not against us. Right. Because
it's a response was like he's full of life,
so full of light. I can't even see his face.
And and then he said. And he has a scroll in his
hand. Mm hmm. And so I was like, then he came with
a message of what is the message? And the message
was a commissioning. So at the very end, I asked
him what his name was because I thought, what
angel is this? You know? And he said, Emmanuel,
right. Wasn't an angel. I wasn't an angel. That
was Jesus himself. There you go. That's why I'm
running for secretary of state. I'm kind of.
Speaker 1: The kid also found an angel in her
washing machine. And then it turned out it was
actually it was actually fabric softener. So what
do we do about that? What? What, what? I mean, I
guess hopefully she loses. Will know that it was
legit because at this point, God and Jesus and
angels are so involved that if they can't get
her over the finish line, nothing can. But this is
unfortunately, this is very common in the United
States. And I know it's really scary for a lot
of our viewers around the world and for children
to hear this stuff, because it is pretty freaky.
But that's a candidate. That's a candidate, folks.